in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Matt
and Rachel are with us hey guys how are
you
welcome welcome were y'all from Dayton
Ohio welcome to Nashville and here to do
a debt-free scream yes sir
how much have you paid off seventy-five
thousand over the course about five
years okay making what kind of money
during that time everywhere from 26,000
and down to fourteen and and then last
year I sort of bumped it up with
part-time jobs up to ninety thousand Wow
what do you guys do for a living I am a
teacher and myself sports marketing sort
of give you a brief heads-up right a
week after we got married I apologize
week after the honeymoon blew my
Achilles found myself unemployed and I
suddenly found the proverbial honeymoon
was sort of over at that point how long
have you been married five years oh so
that's the that's the start of this
story then okay and so it's a lot of
back and forth up and down a
rollercoaster ride to get here what kind
of debt was the seventy five thousand
full gamut everything about thirty of it
was student loans
part of it was cars
part of it was credit cards and then
medical bills medical bills as well as a
couple of businesses along the way okay
all right so when did you buckle down
get serious start doing quote this stuff
that we're talking about here on the
radio because I'm sensing that that
maybe hasn't been the case all the way
through this whole story yeah actually
our pastor before we got married
I'm recommended us to do your class and
as part of our premarital counseling so
so you didn't know about it we did just
due to finances we weren't able to
really attack the way we wanted to do
yeah our debt snowballs
I was gonna say a large aspect of it was
simply keeping the head above water for
probably the first three years and then
over the course of the last a year and a
half or so once additional monies were
coming in we were able to really get
after it there
so the income side of the equation is
what was killing you yes sir yeah so
that makes sense
all right and you've been a teacher all
along sign language interpreter and then
went into teaching when'd you start
teaching two years ago okay all right so
really two years ago is probably when
this really started turning out of the
five correct yeah I think that's when we
both actually were employed at the same
time normally one of us was in-between
jobs for the first three years of
marriage
yeah okay that makes it tough that makes
it harder okay so that's a big part of
your old story is the income fluctuation
back and forth and then the really the
victory on the end comes out of the
equation there's a big part of the story
as well what else do you tell people
when they fit here you've become debt
free when they say how did you do that
what do you tell them the keys are a lot
of it is hustle truthfully what we had
learned over the course of the over of
course the last five years is how much
we were able to still live on very
little but over the course the last
couple years to actually make a dent
into it in and move forward so a lot of
is hard work hustle and unfortunately
you know still married to being each
other's corner for didn't kill each
other in the process that's good that's
good
what do you tell people Rachel you have
to say no like you have to be okay
saying no to wanting a random trip to
Target and even though that dollar
section is only a dollar it can really
add up quick so just learning to say no
to things that don't really matter and
seeing that big picture that was really
hard for me was I really want to go on
this vacation but this bill really needs
to be paid and so just being able to
know that you're know is just the
temporary no and then you can say yes
the things down the road so as long as
you fought this it must be particularly
sweet now that you're there and you're
debt-free how's it feel amazing it's
it's nice to actually see money in the
bank account it's like I don't know
anybody anything fabulous very cool yeah
I was gonna say that that was the
frustrating part is once money was
starting to roll in is
in hindsight if if the bills weren't
there what could have been and obviously
moving forward it is a blessing today
you know and learning to work together
through all that fight that you've been
this there's been a fight for you yes
sir scratching and clawing to work your
way through it well congratulations you
two
very well done Matt and Rachel Dayton
Ohio
$75,000 paid off in five years making
twenty six to fourteen to 90 count it
down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
well done you two very well done I love
it that's how you do it right there hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you are not a victim you're not a victim
of big corporations you're not a victim
of Wall Street you're not a victim of
capitalism you're not a victim of wealth
inequality you're not a victim of racism
you're not a victim
you